I'm here with the beautiful on the inside and out,
my dear friend, Antoni Porowski.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Now you're gonna show us a delicious dish
that pairs well with our gorgeous croque signore.
Yes.
Okay, I'm obsessed with leeks.
And I feel like a lot of people are intimidated by them
because there's always a lot of sand in between the layers,
which throws a lot of people off.
But they're relatively inexpensive,
and when you know how to treat them right,
they're delicious.
And this recipe is literally,
I think it's just like five ingredients,
and it's an awesome little side dish
that you can do if you're having meat,
if you're having fish, if you're going vegetarian,
whatever the situation is.
So what you wanna do is cut off
the really tough green parts.
Yeah.
Most of these have been cut off as long with the root.
Yes.
And then you just basically cut them crosswise
or lengthwise, crosswise, lengthwise.
Halved?
Halved, let's go with halved.
(audience laughs)
And then you just wanna rinse these under water.
These have been perfectly cleaned to get the sand out.
Yeah. Think of it as like clams.
It's exactly, yeah.
You know what?
When you're right, you're right.
(audience laughs)
And you're right about that.
I'm not often right either.
I'm just jealous that I didn't come up with that one
'cause that's actually really, it's very, it's true
'cause they always have sand that comes out.
Anyway, okay, we're gonna make a little vinaigrette
that we're gonna pour over them.
Okay, teach me
how to make vinaigrette.
And be we, I mean you.
Okay.
So we have a little bit of olive oil.
That's lemon juice
and lemon zest.
Which one should
I start with?
'Cause building is important.
Oh, not for this.
Okay.
I feel like it's all
just being mixed.
All right.
A little bit of salt.
Not all of it.
Just-
I was just gonna say.
Yeah, okay, I got nervous.
(audience laughs)
Perfect.
Lemon juice.
And then lemon juice
and zest.
And then some Dijon-
The whole thing?
Or mustard.
Yeah. Let's go.
And then a bit of...
Perfect.
God darn it.
You got it. You got it.
Son of a...
(audience laughs)
Okay.
And then a little bit of fresh cracked pepper.
So we wanna mix that up.
Beautiful.
It's pretty nicely mixed.
There you go.
Just take it away.
Did you get messy?
Oh, I messed up the blouse.
Oh.
He's gonna kill me.
You'll be fine.
And then you just
wanna pour it. (chuckles)
You think I'm kidding.
(audience laughs)
And try to like open up the layers
so that it really goes in between,
so that with every bite, you get a little bit of that
vinaigrette.
Vinaigrette, yeah.
Open her up.
Show the love.
Open her up. (laughs)
Okay, so we have this here.
I'm gonna plop this into the oven.
So that's it.
That's it. That's literally it.
It that's simple.
So what you wanna do is you roast it for a bit.
How long? What temp?
Like 400. (laughs)
400 for 10 minutes?
Yeah.
No, I think a little longer than that.
Like probably 20-ish minutes or so.
'Cause you wanna break down that leek.
You don't want it to turn into mush.
Exactly.
But you want it
to cut nicely.
And then when you take it out, I grate a bit of Parm.
And then basically, do you have...
Oh, perfect.
I don't know, but I wanna get in here.
Get in there.
I'm just getting in here.
Yeah.
Where's my fork?
(audience applauds)
Oh.
Gonna go right in.
So they mellow out nicely.
If you got rid of that exterior layer...
Ooh, that's a little hot.
Mm.
Ooh, nice.
Oh.
It's like-
They're so good.
It's so good.
Isn't it so nice?
(audience applauds)
Mm-hmm.
Mm.
This vinaigrette is perfect, too,
because I still taste the mustard,
but I also still taste the olive oil.
Yes.
Which on dish like this, olive oil
makes it kinda-
You got the sharpness
from the...
I love it.
I was about to wipe you
with bechamel, and that would've been a mess,
but I'm glad that I-
Yeah, but my lipstick has been all over my face
this last two segments.
It's perfect.
Which is the sign of a good time.
There you go.
That's what I always say.
(Drew and audience laughing)
That's three.
(audience applauds)
That's three things my father is gonna bring up.
Antoni Porowski,
I have been on several adventures with you,
and I just hope they never end.
I am having so much fun just living my life with
and around you.
I love you, and I love how much joy
you bring to the world.
I know I've said that before,
but I really mean it.
Love who you are
as a human being.
(audience applauds)
I love you so much.
You're a gem,
a true gem.
Antoni Porowski,
the most handsome, beautiful book.
I'm not kidding, I have two copies.
That's how much I love your book. I have two copies.
Go to our website for all these recipes,
and be sure to get Antoni's latest cookbook,
"Let's Do Dinner," wherever books are sold.
(upbeat pop music)